so good morning to everyone coming over
or dialling in over from at east coast
of the United States and good evening to
the brave souls that they are dialing in
from Europe so Jack redeems just me so
I'm going to skip this but today we're
going to talk about standards and and
before I go deeper into the particular
use cases in biomedical imaging I'd like
to talk a bit more broadly about what
standards are so to begin with standard
little meeting agaric for my NZ cast and
it was possible communicati it renews
maleficence finnegans they can you
believe installation communicati Spoony
buddha vaudeville teacher well if you
haven't understood any of this this is
probably because we have not been using
the same standard because if you look at
it language as a form of the standard or
in other words as standards the form of
a language it's all about communicating
it's all about finding the same level
playing field to be able to exchange
ideas and when we are able to do that we
are able to build things together it's
basically the essence of collaboration
in languages even though usually evolved
over hundreds of years are a form of a
standard I subscribe to you
communicating with using English and
only because of that you are able to do
this because you have also understood
the rules of that language and even
though languages evolve over time over
and as I mentioned ages or Millennia's
some of them actually had been designed
de novo from scratch in other words for
example Esperanto which is not official
language great in nineteen so 1870 which
was optimized for how easy it should be
to pick it up and learn which is just a
neat example of of how people introduce
artificial standards in languages as
well
but languages is are not the only
examples of standard out there's
probably each of you have a computer and
that computer has a plethora of
different parts and connections you can
plug into and and this is another very
common occurrence of standards and and
those connections are industry
acknowledged approved way of
communicating between hardware and
probably you recognize some of the parts
in this picture and this is how I can
buy a piece of Harvard for example a
laptop from one manufacturer and then
buy a microphone or webcam from another
manufacturer and plug one into another
and those two manufacturers they do not
have to work with each other directly
they just need to subscribe to the same
language to the same way of exchanging
information by a hardware connection and
that's how all these different plugs and
parts come along and there are more
examples especially with with the
hardware industry where standardization
doesn't always go that well for example
many of the laptops that are coming out
right now have this new fancy port
sometimes referred to as BCE sometimes
referred to under bolt free and this
part looks exactly the same even though
it could actually provide many different
functionalities that are not totally
compatible so that also shows that even
in the industry hardware world there is
a need for standards that are clean as
well as intuitive both for users and the
manufacturers we can go further for
example the way we deliver electricity
is another form of standardization that
is very important so for any of you who
traveled a little bit outside of your
country you probably noticed that the
sockets in the walls that deliver power
different shapes and most of not for
America it's a it's a specific standard
from NEMA and and most of Europe is also
subscribing to a different standard and
of course there's the UK that has to be
different but that's another way of
benefiting from doing one thing the same
way because if we didn't have a common
way of delivering power to our
appliances and each manufacturer of
appliance would have to basically find
some sort of a deal with that power
provide their or become the power
provider itself which is preposterous
and then we have digital communication
so in other words the internet and
that's another example where agreeing on
a common standard of communicating and
encapsulating information in packets
allows many services built by different
companies that sometimes outright
compete with each other to operate on
the same layer and be able to
communicate with each other for example
both Bing and Google are using the same
tcp/ip protocol to communicate with
their customers and with each other even
though they're at outright competition
and then we also have a higher level of
digital communication the application
programming interfaces or api's this is
a way how modern web applications can be
built very rapidly and you can go from
prototype to a scalable solution very
quickly by using those standardized ways
of scheduling services and receiving
results from plethora of different
things right now we have api's for very
sophisticated procedure for example
detecting faces from pictures or
detecting mood
of a particular person from a recording
of their voice so this thing has been
flourishing a lot so you might you might
ask how how these standards are actually
developed in the industry how how all
these advantages of having a common
language actually come about so in the
industry there are there are a few
organizations that try to help different
industry players to start talking with
the same language one of them is density
of electrical electronics engineers the
I Triple E in other words which is known
in some circles for for publishing
engineering content but one of the big
things they do is working on standards
so one of the standards that they're
very famous for is Wi-Fi or in other
words 802 11 which is an extension of
the 802 standard which is which is just
at the net and and that standard allows
different appliances to talk to each
other
wirelessly and this standard was
developed by Triple E by bringing
different industry players into the same
process and actually has a process for
designing deciding what should be in the
in the final standards and and this
process involve a draft that is then
refined that is then voted upon and if
it has enough votes it basically becomes
a standard and I Triple E is
acknowledging the role of different
players in the industry so here when he
actually comes to voting in many
occasions it's not people voting for a
standard but particular key industry
players voting for what should be they
understand and what should not another
example of a standardization body is the
world wide web concert
so this one is very well known for
higher-level markup language that we use
and then on the internet almost every
day so coming from the very commonly
used HTML which then became became XHTML
through styling such as CSS and images
like scalable vector graphics all of
these things where standards proposed
and working by the World Wide Web
Consortium and right now they enable web
developers to build websites and be
relatively certain that those website
will work and be rendered in in a
similar way across different web
browsers and those who did web
development now that actually adherence
to those standards part different web
browsers has been historically
problematic and quite often there are
some rough edges that require developers
to to work around certain problems
particular tools that do not implement
those standards very well and World Wide
Web Consortium also has a process and it
also involves multiple drafts and
release candidates that are either
advanced the next stage or refined and
this multiple levels of proposals
important because each time you elevate
a particular proposal to a new level
that brings a lot of bells and that
promotes a lot of players to to
contribute time and look at the standard
and basically it's basically a signal
saying hey this will become a standard
soon you should have a look at it now
before it's too late to make any changes
and then finally something much more
relevant to biomedical engineering
there's the National Electrical
Manufacturers Association or NEMA which
is not only famous for
standardizing the electrical plugs in
the US but also for the DICOM standard
so digital imaging and communications in
medicine standard which is widely used
in clinical applications for storing and
transferring medical imaging data has
been used for quite a while I think
history which is the 80s and it has seen
a lot of revisions but it is widely
adopted in different hospital settings
even though adherence to this standard
is sometimes not perfect especially when
it comes to new imaging and and even
more when it comes to cutting-edge
research in your imaging but that's the
industry and I want to talk a little bit
more about standards and context of
research or in context of academia
so here situation is is slightly
different and I would like to explain
where are those differences coming from
but before we actually go into the
cultural changes I would like to point
you to this fantastic resource this
website called fair sharing dot-org
which allows you to search across
different research or academic standards
that are out there so if you are if you
would like to for certain products
procedures or databases you would like
to adhere to a standard and basically
see what other people how other people
try to solve the problem you're
struggling with and this might be a
great point to start basically looking
for standards that already developed in
a particular field that you're
interested in okay so let's let's talk
with how different standards next damia
are quite often standards in academia
come from a sort of bottom-up way rarely
we have these
and organizations that are basically
imposing a standard on everyone else
it's quite of them a few developers
that's actually how how nifty was was
coming around that that CD need for
better exchange of information and less
error-prone ways of transferring
metadata quite often the standards are
developed with a specific project in
mind so for example which is which is
very good they are there to solve a
particular problem for a particular
project which which is good in a way
that it is driven by a practical use
case but it's a little bit more limited
because often those those problems are
constrained or limited by by time by
grants by a particular specific flavor
of this problem in this particular
specific project and open fMRI for
example at a repository of of imaging
data involved with had the same thing
they needed to have some sort of
formalized way of storing data and and
they just came up with something for
that particular project with that
without involving broader community or
negotiations or or any consensus
building and that's that's perfectly
fine and this comes from the discuss
from brother incentive structure in
academia where you basically are
rewarded for solving particular specific
problems rather than building consensus
or or broader collaboration stands
academia also tend to be technically
simple because especially in biomedical
imaging quite often you have a mix of
different levels of technical expertise
and that has to be accounted for
and therefore standards need to be a
basically simpler so people whose
expertise more in the biology could also
benefit from using them and would not
require you know getting a CS degree to
start building and working on top of a
particular standard and sometimes
standards tend to be competitive in
academia certificate unfortunate that
the the way scientists are rewarded is
for making particular neural findings
and quite often that leads to
competitiveness and that leads to a
particular group trying to do something
before another group and the reward only
goes to the first person that does
something and darf that that's why
sometimes we do see some fights between
standards and and we are seeing those
files being fueled by by basically the
incentive structure and how people are
rewarded through grants and then we also
see the same benefits as with any
standardization effort when a particular
standard gets while we adopt it there
are great benefits because suddenly we
can combine different tools and
different sort of different different
software tools because they start
talking with the same language so an
example of that is nifty and neural
imaging research this is a imaging file
format which is very wildly adopted
right now even the despite some of its
shortcomings but because it's it's
implemented in so many different neural
imaging researchers piece of software we
are able to mix and match them and and
build optimal pipelines by by picking
and choosing outwards from different
sources so this is this is great and
this is something that basically applies
in academia and in the industry when we
all start talking the same language
there are great benefits to come okay so
after this brief introduction I would
like to talk about the particular use
case and this is something that I'm bit
more knowledgeable about because it's a
movement I've been spearheading it's a
it's basically an attempt to standardize
how we describe and annotate research
human neural imaging data and I will try
to make it make some broader points
because I fully understand that many of
you are coming from different subfields
of clinical research and not necessarily
interested in in the brain and imaging
but they feel that there are some
take-home messages from this attempt
that could be applied by two different
subfields and maybe some of you will be
engaged in standardization effort and
different academic subfields in the
future and maybe some of these advice
would would be useful for you so let me
give you some introduction and first of
all and I think it's important for any
project you you start is is to think
about your goals so what are you
actually trying to solve because it's so
easy to go into the nitty-gritty details
and and start solving technical puzzles
and forget about the the particular big
picture problem that you are actually
test there to solve so we wanted to
enable reuse of research in reading data
and we wanted to make this applicable
both to data shared within a lab and
between labs so then the stressor is on
reuse of of of data so this is not just
describing data for the sake of having a
complete description of it this is
having in mind the actual application
the fact that someone generates a data
set and someone else takes this data set
and tries to extract knowledge from it
and this again this applies both within
a lab and between labs so even if if you
were to start adhering to standards in
your lab alone that gives you benefits
because it's easier to collaborate with
in this lab with your peers but it's
also easier if you're in a higher
position for example API it's easier to
to move one person from a project to
another or basically reuse some
historical data acquired in your lab for
a new project
we also wanted to enable automatic
analysis of datasets so when you have
enough metadata and they are all
formally described that allows you to to
run analysis automatically and you can
start with small use cases when you just
process the data and automatically and
you extract the metadata and this is
much less error-prone but the the big
picture vision is that we will be able
to go from data to actual knowledge
through semantic knowledge in an
automatic way if we have good standards
for describing the data itself and then
finally we'd like to have tools for for
checking consistency of datasets and and
this is this is important in context of
data sharing where you're receiving data
from different sites and different
groups and you want to basically
validate them relatively quickly and in
an automatic way and we also need to
think about the players so so you need
to have in mind the people that you're
building this for and this will be very
important later on when you decide what
what groups to actually contact and who
are the key players for this thing to be
successful so we wanted this to be
useful for LAPI eyes and they said this
is not just reducing errors and data
handling but also very importantly
enable reuse of data within your own lab
and might sound a bit weird
that I'm stressing out the within lab
use case but with this project we had to
fight this perceived notion that that
this is only useful if you are planning
to share data publicly or widely and
this is not the case it's a it's a
separate orthogonal issue which I'm
happy to talk to any of you at length
later but standardization help whether
you are willing to share data publicly
or not and then we have to talk about
pipeline developers those are the people
who build tools for processing data so
they know very well which pieces of
Medicaid they are necessary to be able
to process the data and then finally
databases and repositories so those are
both developers of the software
securities and managers of these
resources because that enables automatic
data submission and they know very well
what pieces of meth they are asked for
and they have been dealing with a broad
variety of datasets okay and and just
kind of drive home that message of of
reuse within your own lab I usually when
when talking to a new audience about the
standard I I present this hypothetical
situation of Professor Smith
up-and-coming researcher that is running
her own lab and and she just came up
with a new way of reusing old data that
has been acquired in her lab a while ago
and she remembers that this type of
acquire particular PhD student her D
graduated and unfortunately the student
Mike decided to become a business
analyst or a data scientist in other
words in California and he's completely
unreachable and there's no way to get
him involved in this project
and professor Smith is trying to make
sense out of her own data the data is a
quite an own lab but is struggling with
getting lost with this because she found
eventually this external hard drive
lying around somewhere and it's and the
heap of incomplete diagrams and Excel
spreadsheets so this is basically the
use case we were trying to avoid even
within the single lab space so moving on
we also try to acknowledge what makes
such and ever successful and many of
these things that we learn on the job
but hopefully some of these will apply
to future standardisation projects
really I wanted to involve broad
scientific community and that that
basically means that you have to step
outside of the bubble of your own lab
this is this is the essence of
standardization you need to find a
common language so if you only speak to
people who are just next to you that is
much easier but that doesn't enable this
long-range communication and here the
the concept of distance is is much more
abstract so that means talking to
different labs and talking to different
researchers even those that you would
normally not actually interact with and
trying to figure out what are their
needs what are their experimental
procedures so on and so forth and then
sharing the credit of this work is very
important that's one of the the big
changes or differences from building
standards and industry industry and
academia is that and the industry
usually have those panels where
different companies would send their
employees to participate and and make
things work and find the consensus and
so basically have employees that are
paid to work on the standard in academia
this is this is a little bit different
and and usually working toward
standardization is
not something that is rewarded by the
same academic means so that's why it's
very important to share the credit of
the work of a standard so it means that
you have to be truly collaborative and
acknowledge all of the individuals that
were involved in the standard in the way
that is respected in academia so I'm
talking here about character shapes of
papers and other products then focusing
on use cases is extremely important
hello everyone
is Jack Van Horn we're gonna try and get
Kris unmuted here in just a second hang
on just one moment
hang on just one
and folks we're gonna try and get Chris
back here in a second
okay can you hear me now yes we can
Chris Thanks
yeah sorry for that demo night this I
guess so I will assume that I could cut
out at 9:33
well that's East well anyway I the same
side alright so back on track so
focusing on the use cases this is what I
was I was talking about
it's basically having in mind the the
practical uses of the standard in the
future and that's why it's very
important to get involve all these
people that that will be reusing the
data or building tools to reuse the data
involved in this then you have to make
the process public and and also document
all of your calls for comments and
different outreach operations and that
basically gives your effort much more
validity um and then we try to follow
this 8020 rule and this is basically
specific oh sorry this basically means
that we are focusing on 80% of the most
common cases instead of spending 80% of
the time on on the tail of 20% of the
cases that are least common and in other
words we basically don't want strive for
perfection
to prevent us from delivering something
that is good and this is this is
something that you have to remind
yourself over and over again when
dealing with these things because quite
often it's it's easy to be overwhelmed
by the amount of details and amount of
edge cases that you have to cover and
that can slow things down actually to a
halt so that's something that that is
important and finally provide tools so
the standard itself if you don't provide
it in - this is just a long boring
document but it was important to
be able to help people adhere to this
standard is to provide validators and
this is something that the World Wide
Web Consortium excelled very and at
great degree they have validates for
their markup standards and that allows
developers writing web sites to check
whether would they have written adheres
to the standard and I think that's very
important to have or for any standard
and then community it's extremely
important to basically build a community
around your effort to make all the
voices feel heard and have a healthy
conversation about different things yes
remember all these people will be
donating their free time to this effort
so so it's very important to make them
feel appreciated as well and and
building community is probably the
hardest thing about coming up with
standards in academia but it's also the
the most important aspect and on the
topic of community you might be asking
like how do I get people involved how do
I get more people involved and there are
some practical technical things that you
can you can do to make that happen for
example you should strive to ease the
per year to provide feedback so in other
words you're gonna have some draft
documents you're gonna have some
proposals some ideas and those ideas
need to mature and you need to have as
much feedback from the community as
possible to to be able to to turn this
this imperfect idea to something that is
much more usable and and captures
perspectives outside of your own bubble
so practically here we wanted to make it
easy for people to communicate we
decided for an old-school mailing list
because a lot of a lot of experts in the
field are very accustomed with this way
of
exchanging ideas but you also went for
an alternative to that that we follow in
parallel which is an online Google
document that is open for everyone and
anyone to comment even anonymously and
that's that's a great way because you
can just send a link to this document
and I can actually show you how this
works right now you can send a link to
this document so and they can they can
basically immediately not only have a
look at the current working version of
the standard but they can also
immediately say sorry they can
immediately say what they think about it
so in other words they can go here and
they can start commenting on the on the
format as it as it is and as you can see
there are many of people that left their
comma and as soon as this loads and this
is a quick way of getting feedback from
the community that is outside of the
outside of the mailing list and also
provides ways to to give direct
suggestions to the wording of particular
definitions for example and then on the
topic of credit it's very important to
list all the contributors by name if
they are willing to do so and
acknowledge all types of contributions
so there's going to be plenty of work
with any standard and some of it this
documentation service building example
some of this building tools and
acknowledging all of this this hard
volunteer work is very important to make
a thriving community and also and this
is a feeling of shared ownership and
this is something very important because
people should
should know that this is this is a
collaborative product this is something
that that only came about because of a
lot of dedication for many people and
then it's important to organize in
person meetings some things are just
much better than when when you meet
face-to-face and and some discussions
can go really badly only because they're
done over email and finally be
persistent because most people will be
too busy to help you out to begin with
and a lot of people be skeptical in the
beginning because no one knows if your
idea and this particular standardization
project you're working on actually is
going to be picked up is going to become
a standard until it's wildly adopted
it's just a proposal so people don't
know if they should dedicate time to it
in the beginning so lots of patience so
briefly what is bids in more detail I'm
gonna skim through this and it's it's a
way of structuring annotating and
organizing data so in other words it's
not just a set of definitions of
metadata fields but also how particular
files should be named and organized in a
particular storage space and this sense
might sound a little bit backwards to
some people you know especially in the
age of object stores but we found that
this is something that a lot of laws
already do and and that particular
approach was driven by the community
need standards basically at describes
binary imaging data as well as
demographic data for participants in
scans and for that we use CSV files use
Nifty files previously mentions for for
imaging data and then Jason for for
other metadata and all of these fields
are well defined in the specification
itself
you can go too much into the details off
off bits itself because I would like the
messages here to be much more general
but I want to talk a little bit about
the tools that are important for for
making bits bits happen and obviously to
build the api's and there are API is
being built for bits that allow you to
query those data set programmatically in
various languages such as Python or
MATLAB and that's important the sort of
tooling that makes adoption easier that
is that is very important but at the
same time the standard itself has to be
easy enough for those tools to be built
quickly and easily in other words you
cannot build all of this API for all of
the languages yourself so you should not
rely on the fact that everyone
interacting with the data described
using your standard has to use your tool
and then converters there's a lot of
idiosyncrasies and the data needs to be
converted to the standard and that's
what converters are extremely important
and finally validators and I cannot
stress it enough the role of the bits
validator
is very important it basically allows
you and I will attempt to demonstrate
this right now it allows you to on your
own machine point to for all their on
your hard drive with the data set and it
performs validation of the data set
client-side there's no data shared this
is all in the browser using JavaScript
but without any data transfer and it
shows you what sort of errors were sort
of missing method data pieces there are
in your data set and that that takes you
from reading a boring specification to
actually adhering to the standard much
quicker and then we have a process for
creating extensions that's another
important aspect of standardization is
that this is always a live document it
always would be
and it follows a standard procedure that
is similar nitrogen and water web
searching where there are drugs there
are experts involved there are there are
cost for public comments and then we
create examples and we extend the
validator and we strive for consensus to
before we merge it and we are very big
on backwards compatibility especially
because there are so many tools building
on it right now and many of these
extensions are being driven by by
certain individuals that can take up the
role of of chairs of the subcommittee's
and I just want to list some of them
here her name elegance intro Hermits
we'll start Connie working on on some of
these extensions and there are many
others not listed here and some of this
extension actually lead to two
independent academic product so for
example extending bits to M eg has been
described as a paper that is currently
under review and this is work driven
bhar jiyo Marnie sell from McGill but to
sort of wrap it up because I feel that
the time is sort of running out I want
to talk a little bit about the use cases
enabled by bits because sterilization is
all great just have a language to talk
to each other but what cool new things
can we actually do when we have this
standardization and one of the things
that we started doing very early on is
trying to build standard containerized
applications for doing data processing
that can take a standardized bits data
set so so this is a concept kind of
similar what you have on your phone when
you install app audio on your phone
you're never worried about dependencies
or other software that is this this app
relies on so you married this concept
which is called software containers with
taking standardized inputs as
sorry taking stands like bait set as
input so that allows us to to create a
set of the some processing applications
that require minimal metadata inputs and
allow you to very quickly test in a also
very reproducible way different analysis
and different pipelines on your data set
as long as this is in the standard way
and the other thing that we also did
marrying different aspects of these of
these concepts is that we've created a
free online platform for sharing and
analysis of numeric data and this
platform builds on many of the
components that already spoke about but
the important take-home message here is
that the components such as the
validator such as the beds acts are all
independent and there are basically
building blocks that other people can
use to incorporate this into their own
systems and services and website and and
and tools and I think that's an
important thing to emulate because that
again this is this is not about the
single lab this is not about the a
particular set of individuals and you're
trying to build an ecosystem and and to
do this right you have to make your your
components and tools reusable alright so
going back the open neuro so this is a
web platform that uses bits apps and
uses bits to make data sharing data
analysis easier so basically it allows
users to upload data sets to to these
websites open your dog org and then
again the validator exactly same
codebase I showed you before it's being
run before you upload the data so you
know if there are any errors that you
have to correct and before actually
committing to like a long data transfer
process and then it allows you to to
basically when you upload your data set
and create a snapshot of it
it allows you to to choose from a
library of different bids apps or
basically containerize data processing
pipelines and you can schedule a job
running those birds apps in the cloud
that is managed by this by this website
and this is basically how you can
schedule this job and select different
subjects and when you press submit
you're going to get an email after the
job is finished and you can go and
explore results of such analysis and and
I can show you before we wrong a little
bit how such an asset actually looks
like so here we are we're an opener and
I I uploaded my own brain because vanity
I guess you know it's it's it's because
I can actually clearly share my own
brain that is an older project and and
basically as you can see I can I can cut
all the different data sets and look at
different parts of the website and we
have both public and private data sets
but let me just go to my very own data
and another mode I can show you actually
the the jobs as they as they finished
for some reason the internet is acting
up today a little bit and I'm not quite
sure okay there we go so I run a set of
different apps on this particular data
set for example here this is ants
cortical thickness an app which finish
and succeeded I can go through the logs
and I can also look or download to the
results and for example one of the
outputs of this particular pipeline is
it's this image of the of the brain
segmentation
and and when it loves you basically
gonna see how well ants which is a
particular piece of software for doing
structural and functional brain courage
istration and segmentation worked out on
this data set so yes so this is this is
how this works and and just to just wrap
up I would like to thank many or all of
the contributors to bits and the bits
ecosystems can see it's a long and
growing names also long and growing list
of names and institutions that
contributed in different different ways
to this effort and we hope that this
list is going to grow even more and
we're gonna make even better better
standards and I also compiled a list of
resources and that that you can have a
look if you're going to learn a little
bit more about the things that I've
talked about today and that concludes
the try to play NWC processes as well
history of diagram and and some of the
bit stuff that I I talked about and I
guess this is all from me and I believe
that we have some time to take questions
Chris thank you so much for that really
great overview of the need for standards
and why we kind of need to have them
from a practical standpoint and some of
the some of the sociological issues as
well as well as some of these providing
some of these resources for us
one question that I guess I have is very
often you you'll see where there's a new
standard that's being kind of announced
and there's some group someplace that
says oh we've decided that there needs
to be a standard and we've anointed
ourselves as the standard creators and
we're going to make the standard and
you'll all love it it'll be great you
should want it as a end user
how can one be comfortable with this you
know almost this barrage of standards
development and knowing which one is the
most trustworthy
or is it needed and do I kind of make
the leap to you know train change the
way I do my own data a standardization
or rather what what form I put my data
in how do I know when's the time to do
this and how do I know to trust the
people who are saying that oh we've
developed this standard it's great you
should adopt it how do I know well such
an easy question to start with yeah of
course I'm kidding it's an incredibly
hard problem so the the telltale signs
is is adoption but that's a chicken and
egg game yes because someone has to be
the first one to do it right so the
other the other thing that you can go
with is seeing which individuals or
which organizations are actually
involved in this process and if there is
a process and if there actually has been
broad communication about how this has
been developed but at the end of the day
everyone adopting something new is
taking a risk because it might be good
or might not be so there's there ways to
minimize that risk and if you are it's
probably good to commit with a smaller
project may be delegated for you know a
new RA collecting a new data set and
gather some information this way rather
than you know committing a whole
consortium to it to begin with but but
yes this is the struggle and that's why
especially in the early days of birds we
we struggle to get people involved
because they were hesitant because they
didn't know if this thing's gonna pick
up or not I guess everybody has you know
sort of a finite energy that they can
devote to things and if it looks like
they have to do a whole scale you know a
transformation of the way they organize
their data or store it or or
what-have-you
it I don't know for some people that
might be a horrifying thought we
one thing they might be thinking is that
we'll wait a minute you know there's
some new standard is this based on
something I already know so for example
one of our listeners is asking is the
data set description based on the HC LS
w3c data set description and somebody
may say oh I'm familiar with that so
okay this makes sense to me and that
might lower their barrier on the other
hand if it's you know I don't I'm not
speaking about bids in particular but if
people weren't familiar with that they
may say well wait a minute why would I
go and do this because it seems to be
unattached to anything else that's that
I might be familiar with is there any
sort of sociological barrier there yeah
totally and I think that it what is
important here is that they totally
agree that those links that building on
existing solutions is very important but
it's also important to acknowledge that
different communities will sort of
respect and acknowledge or actually be
familiar with different existing
solutions so so for example there are
some unwritten practices in the way that
people organize their data and academic
labs that they are familiar with there
is the imaging data storage format
called nifty that a lot of people are
familiar with and there are some
excellent standardization approaches of
data in the industry that academics
might not be familiar with so it's not
only building on things that are already
there but also acknowledging what your
community is familiar with and what they
gonna basically take advantage of
mmm-hmm how big a role do say journals
play in this and well there's a you know
a lot of interesting sociology regarding
that which we don't need to get into
about what you know for-profit or open
science or like a bio archive or what
have you but journals play an important
role here in that they're publishing our
the research do they have any sort of
I don't know what your experience has
been have they had any sort of buy-in to
the acceptance of standards in support
of the literature that they published so
that the data that's contained in them
is more easily reproducible yes so so in
a way it was rather indirect and and
there were two aspects where were
journals actually contributed to this
one of where it was one was when we were
trying to publish the standard itself as
a paper they've pushed that in the right
direction to to be more transparent
about all the things that we did to
reach out to the community and I think
that was stels very important and and
sort of emphasized our what we knew
already but but it's better to to make
this all transparent and the other
aspect how journals are involved in this
is there's this new breed of of journals
that publish data so so those are data
journals in other words and I'm talking
about scientific data here data and
brief frontiers is doing that you know
informatics is doing that there are
specialized data journals for Social
Sciences and psychology as well and
those journals since they publish data
or data descriptors they care a lot
about the consistency and the
reusability of those data sets and they
usually sort of offload the the burden
of of data
over indirect as for example there are a
few journals that would recommend
repositories that adhere to standards
but they wouldn't recommend standards
themselves so this is how how journals
basically play a role in this right
well like we're at the top of the hour
now and I'd like to thank you Chris for
providing this great overview of data
description standards for biomedicine
perfect perfect addition to our
collection of webinars on in the guide
to the fundamentals of data science I'd
like to thank everybody for joining in
once again thanking Chris and do look
forward to a future of our guide to the
fundamentals of data science webinars
and watch your email for further
announcements about those oh wonderful
thank you very much everybody have a
wonderful day and a great weekend thank
you thank you for having me